yeah so I'm going to write down a little
bit for you Brady fourteen nine seven
two now what's interesting about that
number
it's the subject of a number of well it
is but the thing about a number is its
seemingly not interesting at all okay so
as of a a couple of days ago I've been
reliably informed that this is the
smallest number not to appear in any
sequence in the online cyclopædia of
integer sequences so this this does
actually appear in a definition of the
sequences of coefficient in the
definition of the sequence but it
doesn't appear in a sequence itself the
first number not to appear at all is the
following number so this is seemingly
even more uninteresting so okay and can
they be uninteresting well let's think
about this and it's actually a
mathematical proof in a very common that
says that actually there is no number
that is a uninteresting that all numbers
are interesting is very simple let's
prove it by contradiction so let's
imagine that n we're assuming that not
all numbers are interesting okay so if
not all numbers are interesting then let
the number n be the least an interesting
number
okay so n is the least on interesting
number but now and it's at least an
interesting number so it's interesting
okay so that implies that n is
interesting
okay so you've immediately run into a
contradiction okay so all numbers must
be interesting now of course this is a
this is slightly dodgy they said this
proof this is it's what we call self
referencing it's a bit like statements
like can they can the almighty create a
stone that that he can't move if he's
Almighty you can do anything so you
should be able to create a stone that
you can't move but you know actually
then he can't move the stone so there's
the poem is not much so it's not
almighty so there's something sort of
self referencing in it so what you
really need to do is you need to define
what you mean by interesting so you can
imagine doing that so you say okay
what's I mean what makes an interesting
number well I'll write down a list of
criteria so maybe a prime number is
trusting square numbers pretty
interesting and you write down a list of
things that you think are interesting
and at some point on that list let's say
at the number 28 say wherever you write
down that it's the least an interesting
number is one of the criteria but that's
clearly now this is ill-defined now so
the problem that you have here is is
that the criteria aren't well defined
you need to draw the the conclusion
about a number before the definition is
complete so it's it's fundamentally
flawed as a logical problem but let's
come back to m2 these numbers okay at
the top yeah let's work on this option
of course it is numberphile right all
numbers are interesting right so so
these must be interesting right so so
when I found out about these particular
numbers not appearing in the in the area
is I thought right okay let's describe
something interesting about them so deed
I found something so I was playing
around with them and what I noticed was
was the following
so let's calculate the cross some
possums when you basically take all the
numbers that appear and just add the
milk very simple so in this case it's 1
plus 4 plus 9 plus 7 plus 2 ok what you
get when you do that well you get 23 ok
fine
now look at this one I do it as well 1
plus 7 plus 0 plus 8 plus 7 and you do
that sum and what you get I get 23 as
well that's pretty cool so alright they
both get 23 so that's that's cool and
what did I notice about 23 123 is of
course a prime number so now I thought
well there's got to be I bet you there's
a sequence in the in that list that has
those numbers whose cross on the Pro and
it's there it's been ballistic it's
sequence for anybody wants to check a oh
four six seven oh four this is the
sequence of cross songs who are prime
and so these numbers should really
appear at it but of course they don't go
high enough is this number that really
they should be in it I guess if they
were to do is properly these these
numbers would sue drop out so that's
their proof I think that all all numbers
are are in fact interesting anyway so
just think
about it got me thinking a bit more
about it such thing as a boring number
okay and and I found a definition of a
boring number online and there's
somebody somewhere is to find a boring
number is a number that you can't
express in less than six English words
so for example now janaina and forget
the and nine 999 is is four words okay
so that's not boring so I was thinking
about a think the the first one that you
come across is we 1121 okay so this I
think you need six but never thought oh
I got a minute what if somebody comes
along and says oh that's actually eleven
hundred and twenty one that I could get
it on there but I think 2121 I think
that one is pretty safe nobody is
calling this twenty one hundred and
twenty one if they do that then then
they annoy me so this this is definitely
I think is this smallest boring number
but what's happen there I've just called
it the smallest boring number that's
that's four words so I sort of follow
pile of my criteria again of course this
is all just just messing about
you know there's just not enough of them
to cope with the demands that are put on
them
it says well basically you look at small
numbers you look at sequences of small
numbers and you can be tricked you can
be tricked into seeing patterns which
then don't extrapolate to very large
numbers